-You sort of play an NPR-typ
host on the show.
Do you feel like -- You have
a wonderful voice for it.
Would you like to do a podcast
yourself one day
about horrific things?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-I would love it.
I mean, it's -- it's so fun.
There's such a fun quality
of working
but not having to be on-camera
I think.
You know, just using your voic
or doing something like
animated film or whatever.
It's so interesting.
It's such a different medium
-I feel like for like 20 years
it felt the really smart peopl
were the ones who were doing
animated film.
'Cause that was like
three days' work
on a movie that made hundred
of millions of dollars.
And you just, like,
dined out the rest of your life.
And they're like,
"How'd you but this house?
And you're like,
"I was a raccoon in a..."
-Exactly right.
-"I had two lines as a raccoon
and, like, it was like
a heist movie with -- Yeah."
But you --
But now you like podcasts.
That's the thing.
So you -- I feel like --
Yeah, you got to jump into i
now that the world knows.
-I'm in. I don't know what
I'm going to talk about.
But I would -- I could --
Oh, books on tape.
-You -- Oh, you want to do that?
-I could do that.
-Yeah, definitely.
-'Cause I'm not sure if I have
anything to say, but I could -
You do other people's words.
-I mean, I feel like if you do
a true-crime podcast,
like, you know, you do a littl
research ahead of time.
They don't just, like,
give you a thing
and be like, "What happened?
Explain."
-I have to be
an investigative journalist,
which is really I want to do
or, like, work in the morgue
-Okay, gotcha.
-It's like one or the other.
-You would work in a morgue?
-I am fascinated
by the human body, the anatomy
I want to see the muscles.
-I hope this isn't
a terrible idea.
-Show me the bones.
-You have a podcast.
It takes place in a morgue
and it's called
"Jessica Biel:
Who's in This Drawer?"
And then --
[ Laughter ]
And you just talk it through
It's like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who's gonna finance this?
-I think anybody will.
-Will you finance this for me?
-Yeah. It'll be like
those unboxing videos,
but it's like, "And now...
-Oh, my God.
-"...I am putting my hands
on the blanket.
And I'm gonna pull it back
and, oh, boy.
Look at that."
[ Laughter ]
You were talking to me
backstage.
Your son is 4 1/2?
-Yeah.
-You went to Yellowstone.
When did you do that?
-We go -- I'd say we were there,
I think --
We were there in the summer.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I mean, we go if we can
in the winter always.
-Is he outdoorsy?
Is he taking to the outdoors
-Yeah.
He loves it.
-What do you guys do?
-Well, you know,
we try to go on a hike,
which is about 30 feet
down the trail.
And then you turn around
'cause he did a good job
and he found a stick.
You're like, "Whoo, we did it.
Well, kids with sticks
are basically, especially boys
they're like, "I don't think
we're going to beat this, guys."
-Yeah.
"I feel like we should
go back to the house
and see what I can hit
with this stick."
-That's true.
Exactly.
-And then what about skiing?
'Cause your -- your son's
a year older than mine.
We're talking about,
"Is this the winter we
get him up on skis?"
Have you tried?
-Yes.
We tried, I think, too early
He was 2 or 2 1/2.
-I mean, I've seen videos of
2 1/2-year-olds enjoying it.
-Yeah, so have I.
Not my kid.
-Right, right.
-My kid, he was just like,
"What is this?"
And then you put the skis on
and he was like, "Really?
Seriously?
I can't even move in this
giant -- I'm covered in down."
I mean, he was not
excited about it.
And then I do feel like
if you have a bad first
experience with something,
that will set you back a decade.
-Yeah, I'm worried.
-Yeah.
I'm a little worried
about mine, too.
But, of course, the only -
I hate skiing.
-You do?
-Yeah, I really do.
And I grew up
in a skiing family.
-Why do you hate it?
-It's just like, I get it.
You know?
-You go down.
-Yeah.
-You go up.
-And it's like, "All right
So there's a place -- and that
building over there has a fire
right, and I can
read a book there?
All right."
-See ya.
-Best of luck.
-I get it, too.
-Yeah.
-But I love it.
I love it.
[ Applause ]
-You do love it.
-I love it.
-That's right.
You grew up a skier.
-I did, but I'm a snowboarder,
and I have been for a long time,
and now I have to
relearn how to ski.
-Oh. See, that is another fear
-Which is hilarious.
-Yeah, the other thing is, like,
I feel like when your kid --
if your kid at some age decide
to learn a foreign language,
you could say, "You know what?
I'm going to learn with him.
Because you will look the same
But, like, when adult is
learning to ski with their kids,
you look dumb as [bleep]
-You really do.
It is not a good look.
-Yeah, I feel like
the window's closed.
I'm going to have to make up
a story of like,
"Daddy was too good,
and they told him
he couldn't ski anymore."
-That's right.
"Daddy, get off the mountain
You're embarrassing everybody.
-Yeah. It is always
so lovely to see you.
Congratulations on the show.
And thank you for coming back.
That's Jessica Biel, everybody